the number of things occurred and then
they decided to
kind of pull the shoots made the trades
and retooled as jamal crawford connects
[Music]
crawford working on the big man now
squares up and connects from straight
away
yeah i got i got you yeah i got it that
is one of my favorite places
got one just down the street from my
house really i got you let's try to get
that message across
well and that's really been part of his
mantra
all season long is crawford able to hit
the pull-up
and he wants to foul on that as well
he's getting greedy now
crawford coming right back back into the
game so whatever it was
nothing significant is ganja gets tied
up
[Applause]
[Music]
bridges
well you certainly do not want to appear
as though you're deferring to him just
because it is
a special night 21 year veteran be 41
in mid-june
[Music]
it's a young man's game i know fans all
you know you're running the fans all the
time they always
it's the magic word you look like you
can still play the scoreboard
the agents wonder crawford still
bringing it
32-24 here in this third quarter
thanks in large part to this guy and
he'll add two more a chance to make it
three
head crawford for a moment
[Applause]
robert gibson and the roll
just is this a weird feeling after an 82
game marathon
and jamal was left he was gonna go lay
down somewhere and just rest on his 35
on the drop and the love that's shared
between he and these fans
is special what you play the game for
crawford raising and connecting from
long range jamal crawford when we come
back
jamal take that and not surprisingly
jamal crawford playing this one like
it's a playoff game
like he's 10 years old yes i mean it
really is
yeah at the age of 39. oh my god
he is going to look to add
for to his freezer look at this
as all of a sudden now 13 of 34.
nice drop-off feed to bender all year
though i think he was the sun's best
pass
tough floater and the sun's challenging
everything
and as a result dallas misfiring
crawford
the long-range bomb proud to own that
three-point zone fulton home is donating
one hundred dollars
the sun's charities as he is in lego
heat check noted
45. some exciting one-on-one basketball
here tonight robert working on
jackson and just muscles it up on the
younger jackson
look at josh jackson understand what's
going on here
get him the ball exactly gets the drive
he's got 51.